agora
é o tema que o estrago é acerca do dos
assuntos do futuro mas competitividade -
rivalidade queria convidar vos é é
sermos uma história que tenta comparar é
o que é o que é pra ligar os açores um
barco de papel e os amorim
e é com base nessa história que estava
que nós conversássemos hoje aqui um
pouco é 1895 francisco curto e ao para
cobrar a primeira auto unidos surge usou
num barco de madeira forrado com com
jornais entre a ilha terceira ea ilha de
são miguel foi a primeira autonomia a
fundação da primeira ao time uma
autonomia ainda muito terno mas a
primeira fila surge tiveram é é a idéia
do francisco real era comemorar a
autonomia mas também aproximar os povos
das duas ilhas
entretanto em 1995 até 1975 até ao 25 de
abril as coisas evoluíram 11 horas
divertiram com o estado novo a autonomia
perdeu grande parte dos seus primeiros e
acabou quase pura desaparecer e no dia 2
de abril até o dia 2 de abril de 1986
foi aprovado o estatuto da autonomia tal
qual nós o conhecemos não vai entrar
qualquer estão pequenas evoluções mas
digamos que é a autonomia democrática
fundou-se no dia 2 de abril de 1976 nós
estávamos muito longe dos tempos que que
hoje atravessamos estávamos no tempo do
do telex do fone dos surdos distante do
mundo e das ilhas distantes umas das
outras
só temos uma idéia eu acho que aqui
muitas pessoas que já nasceram nos anos
80 e até alguns nos anos 90
os açores têm um único canal previsão
era de pessoas haviam pouquíssimas
existiam poucas estações de rádio é
existiam alguns jornais e quando não
vivo ninguém via gabriela
portanto era um uso muito muito muito
isolados muito diferente daquilo
hoje o sus estão ligados ao mundo em
tempo real há cerca de um mês vocês
devem ter todos assistiram finalmente
santíssimo foi o fórum do aluno cheque
estava ligado à internet no mundo jo das
muitas dos muitos grupos do facebook com
notícias açorianas e foi surpreendido
por o realizado pelo uma no jardim de
infância muito nosso conhecido que é
urgente mas achei interessantíssimo
eis como os jovens dos surdos de hoje as
crianças de hoje já estão a participar
de uma forma completamente diferente no
mundo global vive em um mundo global de
inverno neste mundo global
para eles é que no tempo da gabriela não
poder ver a gabriel que não via avião é
coisa que completamente imaginava como
podemos falar do sul se ligar comissária
que ligar um corinho a opção que os
trazia do josé mourinho
nós temos visto surgem para falar sempre
muito nos surge numa perspectiva um
pouco de rivalidade quando fundou a
autonomia regional
algumas pessoas venderam que a autonomia
seria o entendido como uma atração dias
tanto seriam nove ilhas que se juntariam
mente na e as entidades seria é ea
região autónoma dos açores e sempre fala
e unir os açores exige estudo a gente
usou muitas pessoas dizem há muitas
rivalidades entre ilhas
eu achei que seria interessante nós
falarmos da equipe vendo o josé mourinho
e que é uma boa perspectiva de
complexidade e e para mostrar como se
pode vencer
se vocês repararem josé mourinho treina
há equipas repleta de 200 com egos
enormes disse button é o espaço
mediático espaço é no próprio clube e
consegue consegue através da sua
filosofia motivos que não têm volta
muito tempo aproximar todas essas
pessoas os amorim está na complexidade
da complexidade assenta na
complementaridade
isto é nenhum jogador é mais do que a
equipa e tudo faz parte da equipe porque
é desenvolvendo o futebol quando
consegue também desenvolver o tema saque
duas frases conhecer as partes 50 tudo
bem como conhecer o tudo sem conhecer as
partes não nos leva a lado nenhum e cada
jogador numa equipas são curtos
hall do pensamento de um tudo é que se
ligam codin é o josé mourinho aos aos
açores e actualmente estava de convocar
para um pensamento que é um caminho o
pensamento do que tem sido a opção os
ursos entende começa a federação dias
são como que uma estrela em cada ilha
puxa para o seu lado criando ali uma
área relativamente escassa eu acho que
os outros poderiam nós poderíamos pensar
nos açores numa perspectiva de maior
complementaridade porque estamos mais
próximos porque já não há distância que
via porque estamos no mundo e sabemos
bem da nossa dimensão no mundo global de
hoje e portanto podemos encarar de outra
forma eu acho que vamos encarar como se
fossemos um ano na go num e e gerou ter
uma idéia de um trio variava em relação
àquela ilha algumas na algumas questões
serão umas ilhas que seguem à frente de
todas as outras possam acompanhar para
que cada ilha tenha com que um caminho e
todas as outras possam vestir a camisa 8
não estamos a tirar infraestrutura
uma coisa que aconteceu muito até agora
podemos ter uma uma perspectiva muito
mais eficiente do que poderá ir pra será
a autonomia dos açores uma das uma das
duas questões que eu acho que aprendi
muito com com essa ideia que vai ter nos
açores e que vai entroncar é no tal
princípio dos açores encontram vindas à
forma como é constituir assembleia
regional do sul
como vocês sabem assembléia nacional dos
surdos é é os deputados são eleitos
maioritariamente porque daí portanto por
exemplo no fundo cada ilha
todos nós sabemos que depois do estatuto
diz que uma vez eleito deputado por
cento nos açores mas não vou adiantar se
no hospital de santarém tem que prestar
contas
os deputados entendem que está contas ao
seu eleitorado ainda oscilante
assembléia onde não é constituída por 50
tarde neste momento 52 membros são
eleitos por por círculos vida e apenas 5
e leite conselho regional que na verdade
quiseram ser pistas não é venham um
círculo regional procura dar uma uma
imagem do jornal
por isso que ficamos a pensar um pouco
daqui por diante é numa ideia de
construir os acessos com complementares
através da complementaridade e do que
isto ia fazer no próprio sistema
eletrônico no fundo da assembleia
regional é o órgão máximo da autonomia
de apresentar a autonomia para que
possamos evoluir neste neste sentido eu
queria dizer é que vamos continuar a
navegar num bar com o mesmo custo total
é defender a autonomia tem uma
perspectiva muito diferente e
complementar do desenvolvimento e seguir
as lições de josé mourinho para termos
uma uma autonomia vencedor do tour